hello everyone I was gonna start with my
Fisher Larsen series today but I still
need to prepare it for a bit probably I
will start it tomorrow but if not
definitely on Monday
most likely tomorrow but yes today is
the first day of the singles Cup 2018 I
decided to cover the game from round one
it's maxime beaugeois Grover's is Magnus
cross and a very important game for this
tournament and for both of them but
we're gonna get back to that we do have
a nice photo challenge it's gonna be a
bit difficult especially if you're not
you know following what's trendy in the
chess world so best of luck to everyone
who are the two gentlemen with Maurice
there there we have it like I said best
of luck to everyone now why is it an
important game for both of them for
maximum Carlson well because this is
Maxime from last year so maxi mashaallah
Grove is the winner of the 2017
Sinquefield Cup there we have Jeanne and
Rex Sinquefield presenting maxime
beaugeois gratin ice $75,000 check as he
did when worst first place the total
prize fund was $300,000 it's the same
this year and if you need a reminder
these are the final standings of the
2017 Sinquefield Cup so there we have it
a Maxime in first place with six out of
nine three months zero losses and six
draws and Magnus Carlsen in second place
with fish monitor and with three wins
one loss and five draws and the one loss
Carlson faced is against machine wash
air dry last year where Carlson had the
white pieces so Maxine played a
brilliant game with the black pieces and
defeated him so a nice a nice
opportunity for Carlson to retaliate and
as you all know the Grantchester were
now features a lot more clutch
blitz and rapid events so sinful Cup is
a classical event so it will be a nice
change of pace so let's see what they
have prepared Maxime opened with e4 and
we have c5 Carlson goes for the Sicilian
defense immediately stating that he is
definitely up for a fight nice you have
three nights to c6 and we have nice to
see three not immediately
busting open the center with the d4
waiting to see what black
and here Crossan goes e5 he goes for the
closed variation we have Bishop to c4
and here as Maurice said that he checked
in the database that measure 37 is the
standard move here so many moves have
been played so many games have been
played using this move were Knight f6
will follow blackwell Castle but here
instead of Bishop to e7 Carson went for
g6 and there were Maurice said that
there was like one game in total played
in you know professional tournaments
between 22 and 2300 rails players and
it's very interesting to see how Maxime
will deal with this will this be a loss
of a tempo for black and will white be
able to take advantage of the of the
weaknesses for example d4 Knight 95 95
there are weaknesses Bishop to f7 so
will Maxime try to take advantage of
this somehow or will he simply continue
developing here at Maxime immediately
went for h4 so Carlsen presented him
with a target Maxime decided he will go
for for this this target h5 by Carlsen
now h5 will be met with the g5 but this
is played h v g5 and the now comes nice
to H to the knight on f3 it doesn't
really have any useful squares in any
near future so we have nice - H -
preparing a maneuver like knife to f1
and later to g3 or e3 depending on how
black decides to develop here cross and
plays Knight to f6 also an interesting
idea was this d6 move and after wife
continues for example Knight to g4 the
immediate f5 e captors an f5 Bishop
captures and now nice to d5 this seems
like an okay idea for black but it's an
engine line and Carlton decided not not
to go for it
so after Knight to h2 we have nice to
have six and now d3
here we have once again a position where
the engine gives knife to F F 1 as the
absolute best without wasting this d3
move but again we have to remind
ourselves Avant you did say it the
hardest move to find in chess is a move
with the night
back so for example after a knife comes
here d69 III here Knight would be
controlling these very important central
squares and black will no longer have
any options of any breakthroughs in the
center with d5 f5 or even a sex can be
met with a 4 you will never be able to
put b5 so white would definitely enjoy
this position but ok after Knight f6 d3
is played and now comes d6 night to f1
Bishop to g4
and now f3 it's very interesting if you
play Queen d2 for example then black can
indeed capture this h5 phone because now
nice to d5 attacking the defender of the
bishop here you can simply play Bishop
to g6 and black is perfectly fine here
in this line where Bishop comes to g4
and maxime replies with f3 here it's
impossible to capture the pawn because
now nice the d5 cannot be met with
Bishop to g6 what is threatening to
remove the defender of the bishop or if
you capture then you get this again two
of your pieces around your attack but
after Knight to d5 if you play Bishop to
g6 now there is no Queen on d2 so you're
welcome to play Bishop captures on g5
the point is of course pinned otherwise
you're gonna lose the rook so white
would be in great advantage here so okay
after f3 cousin has to go back Bishop to
e6 and now comes Knight to e3 Bishop to
g7 calls and keeps on developing night C
2 D 5 and here call some castles also
you can simply go for a series of
exchanges here but after Knight captures
Knight captures Bishop captures black
and castle it's still gonna be a better
position for white and the black didn't
really achieve anything with all of
these exchanges so after night Cassie
capture Sundy when I see the five we
have castles c3 and now rook to b8
cousin is ready to put b5 so we have a
for a peculiar position where Maxime
played both a4 and h4 + h5 and his King
is still in the center but there is no
real way for black to take advantage of
this a6 preparing b5 and now comes g4
so as there was no real way to stop be
five calls and places we have b5 a
captures a capture Sun b5 the bishop is
now under attack and here Maxime after
giving the position some consideration
played Bishop to b3 also an idea was
Knight captures on f6 after Bishop
captures dangle Bishop to b5 again white
would keep his control of the d5 square
and also a very interesting line was
rope to a6 attacking the undefended
night but still after 97 a knight
character special characters and bishop
moves it's pretty much a matter of taste
do you prefer this position with your
rock on a6 or death position but I don't
know it seems like a rock on e6 is a
very nice rook I don't know but okay
after a capture some b5 Bushra back to
be three and then out comes Knight to e7
Knight captures with Czech Queen
captures night and now comes castles
Queen - b7 here with ideas of maybe
pushing before in the future but keeping
an eye on the d5 square Carlson would
very much enjoy pushing d5 and also if
the bishops are exchanged then the F
pawn will become a double D pawn but
also it could be useful in pushing d5 in
the future but Maxine has a way out of
this he plays Bishop captures we have F
captures and now c4 with with complete
control of the d5 square which will
prevent cousin from this central break
and okay across in place before we have
b3 and here Knight to d7 cousin isn't
interested in opposing Mac seems control
of da file we have Queen to e2 and now
comes rugby back to d8 nice the c2 and
now comes nice to be it cousin wants the
riemann over the night over to c6 to
control d4 and the maxime has to keep an
eye on this d4 square so Bishop d3
Knight to c6 now the battle is for the
d4 square and King to g2 as DF pawn will
come come under attack so better defend
it now rope to f7 cousin prepares to
double up on the F file we have rook to
a for
Maxime prepares to double up on the a
file room D to f8 doubling up and Bishop
to g1 now we have the stock to f6
preparing to remain over the bishop or
to b6 as it's not all that useful and g7
rook F to a-1 maxime doubles up on da
file
Bishop to d8 and now comes Rock to a8
Bishop to D it was played so now the
Rope can infiltrate the back rank here
we have rook captures on f3 also
possible here was the Bishop to b6 which
doesn't force anything okay rook
captures rook captures and here after
Queen to d1 it seems that black would be
would be better here there are no
breakthroughs for white white black is
the only one that can create a central
breakthrough at some point if he wishes
it our black can always oppose white now
on da file so it seems like a superior
position then to what my Magnus went for
now but okay rook to e8 rook captures on
f3 cross and decides to give up two
rooks for the Queen Queen captures rook
captures King captures and here King to
g7 was played we have King to e2 and the
now comes Bishop to b6 rook comes to 86
now comes King to f7 rook to e8 we have
King to g7 rook a to a6 King to f7 rook
to e8 and cousin played King to g7 for
the third time and it was in this
position that agree a draw was agreed
upon due to a threefold repetition but
it doesn't really make all that much
sense for example if you try something
like Bishop to a7 with ideas of trapping
the rock you're just gonna improve
White's position because rook to f1
check is coming after King moves then
you simply move this rook and then
whatever you play for example 97 the
other look is coming to f8 and then
you've just helped white develop what
what appears to be a nice attack for fer
gaining basically nothing so here here
cross and sees that he didn't really
gain all that much with giving two rooks
for the Queen and in this position sorry
after King g7 they agreed to a draw so
Carlson was not able to you know settle
the score from last year but you know
it's what happens when you face when I
went to 2800 players okay maxime isn't
2800 just yet but he plays like a 2800
meet in the first round so
no no far fireworks but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Craig weisfelt for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and I would
like to take this opportunity to present
you with a chest comedy video those are
very rare it's made by vehicles of name
it's you know you know vehicle Malfoy he
was present on a couple of my streams
which is little friend
so who I will put a link to it in the
description below it's it's a it's an
attempt at a chest comedy now how how
successful they were I are welcome to
check it out most of the jobs are very
cheesy but you know they are kind of
funny and the chest chest comedy videos
are so rare that you know I I don't
think we can really afford to be picky
so it will be the first thing you will
see in the description below feel free
to check it out and let me know what you
think so
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon if I manage to prepare
the official series for tomorrow if not
we're gonna check out a couple of more
games from the 2018 Sinquefield cup and
okay we can check out this nice photo of
Maxine with his big cheque for the end
of the video thank you all and I'll see
you soon